so I am the third director of this lab
called the space systems design lab the
lab has been around for about 10 years
now and the lab got a reputation for
cranking out satellites that were
reasonably small so they could be easily
integrated on two rockets where somebody
said hey a little bit of extra capacity
would you like to ride along with me and
pretty quickly as well we're talking
about students get in and out of the
program and build a satellite in the
course of one to three years and gets
launched we collect the data from it the
guy who started this lab Bob trick
professors loft wigs he had this concept
for what we called a CubeSat and this
was a roughly 4 by 4 by 4 inch satellite
now its measured actually a metric
system so it's 100 by 100 100
millimeters it's allowed to wait a
kilogram it has this particular shape
and his idea was hey could we get to the
point where rather than know that you've
got a particular launch two and a half
years in advance and you've got a plan
for that particular rocket you're going
to be dealing with those organizations
and all that how about if you could just
make a satellite of this size and put it
in a FedEx box and send it somewhere and
the next thing you know it's on what the
important thing is that in this
environment for these kind of rapid
developments typically the satellite is
not you know a sort of a
high-grade aerospace military that's
sort of quality it's put together
choking on a shoestring it's put
together by student labor oftentimes
guys and girls who haven't done anything
on the satellite before so they don't
know all these procedures and protocols
that are using more famous satellites
whatever and yet if you look at the
reliability record and all that these
satellites work pretty well so this is
an example of an intended design so it's
happening right now for a satellite new
building here it has two transmitted to
receive antennas and it's such that
while it's flying on orbit these two
antennas oriented 90 degrees to each
other will give us the best possible
signal down on the ground to them
closely linked and talking you can see
this is made from tape measures a lot of
you can go to to the bar has a museum
outside of the Washington DC and you'll
see satellites it was built by student
groups like the 60s and 70s I think also
use tape measures state measures have
this great property there they like to
control in a very subnet so you have it
on orbit now let go and Austin I've got
these antennas on but he intends have to
be folded up so they can actually fit
inside these people which is just
launching too just like a
jack-in-the-box so I'll kind of get
folded in putting the tube and then it
gets
you